Now we've finally reached the end of our course today, but before we end we want one more workshop, and that's going to be
working in Sequencer.
Sequencer is a cinematic and video creation tool. It can be played at runtime or as an output video.
You can create gameplay animations, baking out an animation,
you can even trigger events and logic as well as receive it, and finally you can even edit them with a curve editor.
That's all within Sequencer.
So let's begin.
So back here in the engine in order to get started with creating our animation we need to select a character.
In this case we're going to use the SKM bot or the skeletal mesh, and we want to make sure we have him selected.
Now the next thing you're going to do is come up here to add a level sequence.
Click on that. You're going to get to ask what name you want to name it. I'm going to overwrite this one.
This was just one that was previously created.
If you were to replace it, which I do, and
now we want to add our character into the sequencer to create a channel to animate.
So to do that make sure you select it, come over here to track,
actor to sequencer, and add SKM bot. Now if you see others listed here, that means you've got multiple things selected.
So let's go ahead and click this, and now sequencer will open. Now you'll notice there's multiple things here.
We don't need this control rig that's attached. You'll see little squares there. We won't need that for today's lesson. So go ahead and delete that.
Now the next thing we want to do is we want to add our animations.
So the first one I'm going to do is I'm going to add an animation with this little plus sign here,
and I'm going to look for the idol.
Now the robot's idol is a little slow to see, so you may not see him breathing in and out, but that's okay.
I'm going to grab this by the right, and I'm going to drag it to make it a little shorter.
Let's say about 15, 16 seconds, no set time.
Then I want to add another animation at the end.
So I'm going to bring it clear to the end of that particular animation where he snaps into place,
click this plus sign, and I'm going to look for a walk, which is that A bot walk.
We're going to click it right at the end there, and I'm going to do something else here.
I'm going to hit control C and control V here. Now I want to show you something.
Let's say you have your scrubber and you weren't paying attention where it was at, and I just hit control V.
Well, you're going to notice then your other animation is going to be inserted below on a separate channel.
We don't want that. We want to blend our animation.
So I'm going to grab it and manually drag it right back up there.
So key point, wherever you have your scrubber is where the animation is going to be inserted.
All right, so this is all great and set up, and we could hit play,
and he's going to walk a little bit in place and then idle. Boring, right?
Okay, so what I want to do is I do want to shorten this and bring it right to here
because that's about as long as I want it.
It's the nice little short animation, and I'm going to then do something here where we blend our animation.
But before that, we want to set some keys, right?
So select your SKM bot right at the zero.
We're going to hit S to kind of get him started there.
Then I'm going to bring him here to where he's going to start to walk.
It's about right, let's say right about there and hit S.
Okay, now I'm going to drag the character.
So I'm going to bring it out here a little bit.
I'm going to drag him, let's say just about right here, maybe right there.
That looks good.
But of course, you need to drag your scrubber where you want him to end.
So let's end it right about here.
Now drag your character to about right there, hit S again.
And we'll go ahead and just put another S here just for the fun of it where he stops.
And now we have all of our keys added.
Now typically, you won't always want to do that because you're going to have some
root motion involved.
But in this case, for the way this works, we're going to do it.
Okay, because it's a walk in place.
So we need to force him to tell him where to go.
Other animations, you may have a walk where he actually walks the distance.
And those are a little bit more preferable when you're working with these
kinds of animations.
But I want to show you can do it still with a walk in place animation.
So let's go ahead and bring them back here.
I'm just going to hit play.
It's just a super simple slides animation.
So there's the thing about that you want to make sure that the distance that you
travel is a little bit less so that the walking looks a little more or less like
it's sliding. But for now, we're going to use it.
Now there's some other methods that we can do to blend animations.
So I'm going to show you that.
So right here, we have this animation, go ahead and select that.
I'm going to zoom in with my control and middle mouse wheel to let you see a
little closer in.
There's this way of interpolating your animations.
Now it may or may not work real well with this type of animation, but we're going
to try it here.
So I'm just going to drag this over, let's say about to 12 or so maybe.
And you're going to see, if you zoom in here, you're going to see this
little curve line.
This is the interpolation.
Okay.
So what's going to happen is, is as we drag this over, we're going to start
to get some blending of the two animations.
Now may or may not be the perfect thing.
As you can see, he's still kind of sliding.
So it's kind of like the moonwalk.
But this is what's going to happen with in-place animations, but you can
clean it up more by changing the interpolation type or extending this
blending and maybe even putting a key here at the beginning, whatever way.
I'm going to leave this to you to clean up for that, but this is the
basic way of getting some interpolation.
Now there's some other settings that we can change.
Right click on here, come up here to properties, and there's some, all
sorts of other settings that we can do.
We can add notifications, we can change the offset, all sorts of great things.
But what I want to do is come up here to option, and I'm going to select
just any one of these, like a quadratic out, so you can change the
interpolation of that curve and set it there, and it can make a decent
change, get a little less sliding when he's moving, but not too bad.
And again, like I said, you could change this with adding other keys, but
to kind of move along so we can kind of see some of our other
interpolation ways, we can highlight all of our keys.
Let's zoom back out, which you can also hit the home key and that'll
bring everything into frame.
And we can just select all of these and right click the key and
change the interpolation type here.
So if you do linear, which makes it a little smoother, not a lot, but
it does make some nice adjustments.
He's a robot, so he's allowed to slide, right?
Okay.
And then I'm going to pull this a little closer.
I noticed there's a little gap and I am going to grab just this particular key here.
I'm just going to pull them back here.
So that he blends a little better and I'll even drag this little in time
here and grab this little key and bring everything in just quick
cleanups that we can do on the fly.
Now there's another last interpolation type that we can do where we can
select our character animation and blend it by the root.
So we know these are root animation.
So what we're going to do is we're going to right click.
We're going to come up here and look for match this bone in the next clip.
So right now it's turned off.
So if we were to select the root, that what that's going to do is it's going
to blend the root motion in place of where this is at with the item.
So that'll give you a little bit more of a nice blend together.
Now, if you recall, we had that socket that we added.
So let's work with that to add this to our animation.
So we're going to need to add it to our scene.
So let's go back to content browser.
And if we recall, it was the backpack.
So I'm going to go back here to the bot mesh characters, backpack.
Now you could type in backpack and do a search for it,
but I already know where it's at.
So I'm going to go ahead and grab that skeletal mesh and just insert it here.
Just have the place specific, just kind of get it into our scene.
Then I'm going to go back to sequencer and with that selector,
let's go ahead and put this at the zero point.
Can you can hit this little key here?
And we're going to add it. So it is selected.
So we remember hit track actor to sequence backpack.
Okay. Now you're going to see it there and you'll be okay. Great.
We have our backpack and we have our character.
So let's see what happens. Yep. Doesn't travel.
Cause we have to assign it to our character in order to do that,
we need to tell to be a part of the skeleton of the character.
So let's go ahead and click on the add button here,
right beside the backpack. And we're going to attach this.
So we're going to hit attach new binding where I look for the SKM bot,
and we're going to select it and we're going to look for our socket
right there. These, the backpack socket highlight that and select it.
You're gonna notice it goes right there. Well,
that's because there's an offset.
So we need to make sure that we have that set.
So let's go over here to our details and you'll notice,
if we pull this out a little bit, our location has an offset.
So if we hit this little arrow here,
it's going to snap right to the socket and there it is there. Okay.
Now let's see if it travels, if it travels along, we are set.
There's our animation and the backpack goes along for the ride.
There we go. So this is your final animation,
your very first one you've ever created.
So now we want to bake it out and be done with our character.
So I'm going to go ahead and right click on the SKM bot,
and I'm going to bake an animation sequence.
I'm going to search the folder where you want to put it.
Let's say, let's just put it into our class folder, hit okay.
And we're going to get a little menu that's going to pop up window menu
that's opening up here and gives us this little export.
You can leave everything on by default and just export your animation.
And you'll see over here, we've got an animation and you should recognize
this one of the pops up, which is our animation sequence editor.
And you will see that there's our new animation and there it is.
This is how it looks with the backpack and walking and we're done.